hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee  here from mkbhd and welcome to another  little hd video so now that you guys  have seen my unboxing of the sanyo zak d  cg 10 hd camcorder i figured i would  give you guys a little uh first  impressions video of the actual video  footage before i continue to go on and  film with this camera so just go ahead  and enjoy this sample footage section of  the video as well as the 10 megapixel  camera still footage that i've all  blended here together just to uh give  you guys a good idea of the quality of  this camcorder so please enjoy and until  the next video thank you for watching  mkbhd signing out  so  do  you